dwayne johnson's daughters are at it
again
so much fun yeah we could tell by this
girl dad's ear to ear grin even as he
looked for an eye wash station
the red notice star shared this sweet
moment to instagram on sunday hanging
with six-year-old daughter jasmine and
three-year-old tiana my favorite part
about being a dad is it's the little
things and those little things include
some pranks now and again
oh what do you mean put my face down get
down
don't hit me either
wait a second i smell something
[Laughter]
[Music]
in the caption duane explained his
surprise was a mixture of toothpaste and
shaving cream which he confirmed quote
stings the eyes and this follows a
similar prank dwayne's girls pulled last
month
i trust you jazzy
[Laughter]
i hear a lot of foil
[Laughter]
and back in december for jasmine's
birthday she celebrated by using dad's
face as a canvas
wait a second
eyeballs why are eyeballs on my forehead
i don't know if that's a good idea
yep dwayne will do whatever it takes to
make his kids laugh even dressing up as
jasmine's favorite pokemon she saw a
character out they were at a pumpkin
patch there was a pokemon somebody
dressed up as pokemon and she
went crazy
and it's so much so it made an impact on
us that we thought you know what
got to be pokemon
[Music]
you could see her through obviously the
holes in the eyes and she's going crazy
she's loving it i'm sweating my ass off
in this thing
like jesus
that's what daddy's doing
we love that the rock is an accomplished
wrestler actor and entrepreneur but his
best title no doubt is dead
[Music]
[Music]